ah in intros attack on titan season 3
part 2 episode 1 if you're looking for
the history of the Titans that starts on
episode 8 so you can find that here way
to kick things off following Edun and
the other Scouts on their mission to
retake la marea the first step is to get
to Chicago which is where a Danada mean
and Mikasa grew up this will also be
their first time returning home since
Eden's mom met her untimely demise once
inside the district they plan on using
Eddins hardening ability to seal both
the outer and inner gates which were
breached by the colossal and armored
Titans in season 1 upon arrival they run
into no resistance not even a single
Titan is spotted and Edden easily closes
up the outer gate as they move to block
the inner gate Ottoman gets a hunch that
the enemy could be watching them from
inside the wall so they all split up to
check for holes in the wall well looking
one of the scouts discovers a cavity in
the wall which cues Reiner to launch a
surprise attack now that his hiding spot
has been discovered he manages to kill
the soldier that found them but Levi is
on top of him instantaneously after that
trying to deliver fatal blows he's
barely able to survive though allowing
him to proc his transformation as he
transforms the beast Titan appears along
the inner wall with a bunch of other
Titans cutting off the scouts escape
route
episode 2 Titans new target becomes the
horses in order to prevent any
possibility of retreat so the scouts
have to move to defend them we also
learned that Levi wasn't able to kill
rider because he transferred his
consciousness into his body right before
the strike landed preserving his life
every guy knows that if he had this
ability he would immediately transfer
his consciousness to his dick just to
see what happens two great minds come
together for the purpose of Education
what's more beautiful than that but back
to the story as Reiner is planning on
killing all the horses he sees a DIN
transform and decides that he can't
ignore the possibility of him escaping
this is all a part of the plan because
Edden agreed to be a diversion to keep
the horses alive Eden begins to fight
with the armored Titan and now that he
is able to harden his fists he can
actually do damage through riders armor
well they have their little skirmish
Mikasa and [ __ ] plan to unveil their
new weapon designed to combat the
armored Titan called Thunder Spears they
catch Reiner off-guard and used the
Spears to penetrate the armor on his
neck the second volley of Spears they
let loose reach riders real body and
explore
presumably killing him in the process
episode 3 we come in on a flashback of
the trust mission in season 1 where Eden
uses his Titan form to move a boulder in
front of the district's outer wall
during the mission Marco who we know
died on the mission under mysterious
circumstances had overheard Reiner and
Bentall discussing their plans and
revealing their identities as Titans
Reiner restrains him and he forces the
reluctant Annie to remove his maneuver
gear leaving him helpless to be
attacking Titans he is then eaten alive
by an approaching Titan as the three of
them watch jump back on up to the
president over the Reiner who was
presumed dead until his Titan suddenly
screams this signals the beast Titan to
hurl a barrel with better felt inside
over the wall into the district while
she fears that the impact of the
colossal Titan could kill them so they
are forced to retreat leaving Reiner
behind this allows battle to reach
Reiner and he concludes that he isn't
dead he just spread his consciousness
throughout his entire nervous system as
a last resort he then goes on to have a
verbalist conversation with ottoman
who's trying to talk him down after the
negotiations break down we get a quick
look at Reiner who's now regenerating
and Beth thought finally takes on his
form as the colossal Titan II of zero
for Levi and his men were charged with
handling the Titans coming from inside
while Maria where the Beast titan is it
seems like they're making pretty good
progress killing off all the smaller
Titans but then the beast ein hurls
rocks at the Scout severely injuring or
killing most of them
this leaves Levi and Edwin stuck between
the be Stein's rock valleys and the
colossal Titan closing in on their
position from the other side of the wall
headin and the others are forced to move
against the colossal Titan to try and
prevent him from reaching Levi and the
horses this doesn't go so well as Eden
gets punted out of commission and the
others can't really do anything because
the Titan steam prevents the thunder
spears from being effective back over to
Levi and Edwin who decide that the only
option they have now is to launch a
counter-attack
Edwin plans to leave the remaining
Scouts on horseback in a suicide charge
at the bee Stein in order to give Levi a
distraction to reach and kill the Beast
Titan in the final scene we see that the
charge is underway and getting pelted by
rocks with Edwin being hit as well yep
so bot
it only takes three rockball eyes from
the Beast Titan to thwart the charge
completely with all of the scenes they
showed up Marlow I actually thought that
character was gonna be relevant in this
anime but then he goes and eats a head
shot from one of the rocks so I guess
that's not happening oh my gosh right in
that bouquet
Oh God satisfying thankfully they bought
enough time and Levi is still a Chad so
he dumps hers the bee Stein and rips the
pilot from the Titans body you should
remember at the end of season 3 part 1
Levi was entrusted with a Titan serum
Kenny was originally the one who stole
the serum off of Rod race but then ended
up dying shortly after passing along the
serum to Levi he plans to use the Titans
serum to transform one of the surviving
soldiers so that they can eat the pilot
of the bee Stein and gain his beasts
heightened powers he doesn't want to use
it on himself because he wants to find
an injured soldier who's going to die so
he can save their life in the process
unfortunately his plan gets messed up
because another intelligent Titan
snatches away the pilot and begins to
make their escape Levi is unable to
pursue them because he is left fighting
the remaining Titans hop over to Ottoman
who discovers that the colossal Titan is
actually skinnier than before and
devises a plan to deal with him Edun is
still unconscious but ottoman needs him
for his plan so he gets to him to wake
him up meanwhile Reiner has now
regenerated and is headed towards them
so Mikasa and the others are sent to
slow him down automate puts his plan
into action with Eden pretending to fall
unconscious off of the wall I don't mean
attaches himself to the colossal tines
so that the colossal Titan will fight
back releasing its steam to attack him
Ottoman holds out for as long as he can
to make him burn as much flesh as
possible draining his power this is all
just a successful distraction though so
that Edden has time to harden himself
and seal off the inner wall of the
district after it's been sealed he uses
his maneuver gear to surprise Berthold
and rip him from the colossal Titans
body our demeans plan had worked out but
it came at the cost of his life as he
was turned into a human marshmallow
[ __ ] shows up clutching the fight
against the armored Titan allowing them
to use thunder spears to blow Reiner
from the armored Titan body episode 6
surprised the human marshmallow is still
alive who could have ever guessed Edden
encounters the Beast Titans pilot for
the first time and he finds out that the
man knew his father claiming that his
father had been lying to him who doesn't
get a chance to elaborate on what
exactly his father was lying about
because terminator levi comes over the
wall looking for him so he is forced to
flee with the supply titan vowing to
come back and save at it at some point
over to [ __ ] who is with the captured
and crippled Reiner trying to get
answers from him before they can get
anything out of him the supply Titan
shows up and snatches him away all the
side characters are low on gas so they
can't pursue him allowing his escape we
meet a new sad character named Barak who
appears to have some sort of organism
growing on his head but up brings the
dying
Edwyn to where Levi's Eden and a living
marshmallow rat the rest of the episode
is pretty much just all of the
characters arguing amongst themselves
trying to convince Levi to either save
Ottoman or Edwin with his Titan serum at
first Levi is set on using it on Edwin
but then decides against it because he
wanted him to rest in peace with his
decision made he goes on to inject odd I
mean with the Titan serum I was really
ready for him to turn into a disabled
Titan and then they'd have to like cut
up bad bolts and spoon feed him like a
toddler but instead he just turns into a
normal tine and eats him which is good
because then I'll never have to say his
godforsaken name again once he's done
consuming him odd Amin is able to turn
back into a human and he also gains the
colossal Titans power II episode 7 I
don't mean regains consciousness and
it's filled in on what happened with him
in Edwin Eren Mikasa odd mean [ __ ]
Levite Connie Sasha John and Farokh are
the only ones to survive the mission and
are all that's left of the serve
core once they're done bringing Ottoman
up to speed Adam Levi hanji and Mikasa
head to Eddins basement to learn what
his dad was keeping in there they find a
photograph and written on the back
states that there are people living
outside the walls after the credits we
see Eden's father Grisha as a child with
his sister Fei Jaeger being raised in a
place called Marley they both break the
rules and leave their and term is owned
without permission sprinting past one of
the guards Ganesha was just trying to be
a good brother and take Fay to see an
airship landing station because she
loves airships and dreams of owning one
he was holding this is the big one
people so bear with me when the kids
finally arrive at the station they are
spotted by two guards named Ed and kuru
guard and gross as punishment for
leaving the internment zone Grisha is
beaten by edon while his sister is taken
back home by gross unfortunately Fey
never actually made it back home and her
body was found the next day we then get
some back story from Canisius father on
why exactly their family is being
repressed according to the Marlene
history 1820 years ago their ancestor
Lumiere fries made a pact with the devil
and obtained the power of the Titans
after her death her soul split into the
nine Titans who then went on to build
the LD an empire benign Titans used
their power to destroy the country of
Marlay in order to rule over the land
the term subjects of Umiat is born which
refers to people who can turn into
Titans they originated from you Mia
fleets and eventually the bloodline
spread to the majority of the LD ins but
anyways for 1,700 years after that the
LD and Empire persecuted other races in
what was viewed as an ethnic cleansing
the merlion people couldn't just stand
by and watch his travesties happen so
they conspired against the LD nation
from within this led to them getting
control of seven out of the nine titan
powers now that they had the majority of
the titan powers this sparks the titan
war that happened eighty years ago the
moral aliens emerged victorious and the
LD and king is forced to retreat to
fight a detail island where he
constructed the three walls leaving some
of his people like Greece's family
behind instead of killing the LD ins
that were left behind the more lanes put
them in internment zones which is where
Ganesha was forced to grow up where you
jump ahead just to
it's where Ganesha is now an adult and
working as a doctor a man named rice
approaches him claiming to have
information about how the marlane guard
gross was the one responsible for
killing his sister after learning this
he joins a movement hoping to restore
the old LDN empire to its former glory
they're all taking orders from an
individual who infiltrated the
government known as the owl now let's
jump ahead just a bit to where we meet
Deena frites who joins the movement and
is the last member of the royal
bloodline remaining on the continent
Ganesha likes what he sees so he makes
some power moves and gets married to
Deena we're gonna assume the honeymoon
was successful because soon after she
gives birth to their son Zeke some years
go by and the more lanes begin selecting
LD and children from the internment zone
to be warriors Ganesha devises a plan to
infiltrate the walls and steal the
founding Titan power in order to
accomplish this he wants to send his son
Zeke to enlist in the warrior program so
that he can get inside the walls
Zeke wasn't billing this plan though so
he decides to write his parents out to
the marlane authorities Ganesha and the
other members of the movement are then
taken to the island of potted Ito when
they arrive he ironically finds ghosts
there the butter ball that was
responsible for killing his sister
Ganesha is forced to watch as all of the
other members get injected with Titan
serums and turned into pure Titans
they are then forced to roam the island
for the rest of their lives as
punishment for their crimes Ganesh's
wife Deena is also injected and it's
revealed that she is actually the Titan
who killed
Eden's mom and Hans it's around this
point we find out that edit is seeing
all of these memories in a dream because
he ate his father to gain his Titan
powers in season 3 part 1 this leads to
the memories of his father being
transferred to edit and are now starting
to surface I feel obligated to point
this next part out Edun probably saw his
own conception let's just be realistic
while he was digging through the
memories there's a good chance he he
came across some nasty archives sizable
and even if he did see that I'm not
saying he did but if he did that's still
not as messed up as me causes hair but
anyways back to the flashback Ganesha
calls out girls for killing his sister
after some monologuing kuru geta who is
the guard that beat Grisha as a child
for leaving the internment zone
steps in and pushes good ass off the
wall to be eaten by the Titans below
kuru get is then revealed to be the
apple the important that Grisha and the
movement were taking orders from he
turns into a Titan and starts wiping out
all the nearby Marley and soldiers he
episode 9 guru gur talks with Grisha and
explains that he needs him to inherit
his Titan power to infiltrate the walls
and skill the founding Titan power when
kaliesha asks why he can't do it Kruger
explains that when a person receives one
of the nine Titan powers they will die
thirteen years later which is known as
the curse of yumiya cucit had received
his power 13 years ago and doesn't have
much time left so he wants to pass it on
to Grisha in order for him to finish the
job
if the curse of you Mia is a real thing
then edit only has 8 years left to live
side note when someone carrying one of
the nine Titan powers dies without
passing along their power a baby that is
a subject of yamir will inherit the
power in each of the nine Titans has its
own name and Eden is in possession of
two of them the attacked Titan and the
founding Titan everyone heads back to
report to Queen Astoria and the other
higher-ups and trusts well they're Eddin
develops a new theory as to why he can
control the founding titan power without
being a part of the royal bloodline
since dina was a part of the royal
bloodline after he made physical contact
with her titan at the end of season two
that may have somehow unlocked his
ability to control the founding titan
power he keeps this theory to himself
because he isn't sure how others will
respond to this and the last scene could
have got a mentions aadmi name he causes
names without knowing where the memories
of them were coming from he of his Oh
ten the higher-ups and historia decide
to release all the information they have
gathered about the Titans and the
outside world to the public they also
informed them that they're basically a
world with the outside world and the
Marlins are planning an invasion to
secure natural resources during a
ceremony everybody has to kiss his store
to his hand when Adam makes physical
contact with historty have more memories
come rushing back of his father begging
with fraida who had the founding titan
power at the time this was right after
the first attack on she gonna in season
one pretty show was requesting that but
I did use the founding Titan power to
help the civilians escape from the
Titans since Pineda is a part of the
royal bloodline she's forced to follow
the will of the
first king and refuses to help in it was
originally thought that he wanted the
tie in powers for himself but in
actuality he was just desperate to help
all of the citizens in the coming months
soldiers continued using the giant titan
killing hammer to clear out the
remaining Titans inside wall Maria once
all of the Titans inside while Maria had
been killed the survey corps begins
expeditions outside the walls again led
by hanji as the commander since most of
the Titans were inside wall maria and
killed by the titan killing hammer they
met no resistance on the expedition
outside the walls the scouts arrive
where eden had seen his father's
memories taking place and for the first
time they see the ocean
it's nice or whatever for now but they
realized that they still have enemies
beyond the ocean and they need to figure
out how exactly to handle them I'll be
doing the future season and that'll be
on the left side whenever I finished
with it or you can check out all the
attack on Titan recaps from this
playlist here you can also find the
links in the description below and the
only thing I hate more than intros is
rows
[Music]